[Musique]
championnat
non
[Musique]
à
le voleur une baguette a comme objectif
d'atteindre une coordination absolue
entre l'esprit et le corps
il aborde les qualités essentielles à un
bon gars
il apporte aussi aux pratiquants de
nombreux atouts dans la vie de tous les
jours tels que la santé la paix la
confiance en soi
l'humilité le courage et le planète
le commerce est
un combat des sports de carla le sud est
c'est ce qu'on fait pour devenir un
guerrier un peu par as encore grillé
pour bataille dans la guerre
c'est un art ancestral il ya près de
cinq mille ans donc c'est l'origine des
arts martiaux donc de cet art martial
complet autant pour le corps et l'esprit
qui allie l'aspect spirituel et aussi
l'aspect
bien-être comme je le disais et sans
toutefois avoir de douleur c'est à dire
qu'aucune blessure donc tout se fait de
manière fluide comme l'eau les armes du
viennent une extension du port ont
contrôlé par l'esprit enfin d'aboutir à
un haut degré de perfectionnement dans
les combats dring dring dégage un igloo
et triple champion du monde est sympa
champion académique de la roya tôt et a
été consacrée m de quelle année pie hat
et en 1998 selon la tradition
son élève fait des aiguilles et pratique
le pèlerin et plus de quatre ans
[Musique]
l'art martial est basé sur des postures
animal
donc il ya des peuples d'antan qui
observer les animaux et qu'ils ont
elissa sous forme d'un art martial pour
apprendre à se battre donc il observé
par exemple et chats
les sangliers les lions
boissons
en ce moment il ya des corps épars 200
personnes quand larry se donne bonne
préparation
ça permet aussi d'avoir sur cet aspect
bien être d'un côté et
savoir se défendre voilà autant aux roms
que pour femmes
m